breaking news overnight a deadly and
tragic outbreak of severe weather in the
nation's midsection
several states were battered by high
winds and possible tornadoes tornado
watches and warnings were posted in nine
states from texas to the great lakes
power is out in several places one of
the hardest hit places is western
kentucky where the governor says he
believes possibly more than 50 people
have been killed that death toll is not
yet
confirmed
a roof collapsed at a candle factory in
mayfield apparently trapping workers
inside in and around st louis fierce
winds toppled trees and smashed windows
there the reports of injuries but no
reported deaths there as of now but in
tennessee at least five people were
killed when a string of suspected
tornadoes barreled through parts of
arkansas and tennessee overnight
including a nursing home in monette
arkansas about 60 miles north of memphis
in the small town of samberg in
northwest tennessee trees came down and
caused some damage even knocking this
truck on its side
and in edwardsville illinois about 25
miles east of st louis the roof of an
amazon warehouse collapsed during a
storm reporter jenna ray of our st louis
station kmov is there jenna no light yet
but people starting to see this damage
good morning
good morning you guys it's really been
all hands on deck situation since about
8 30 central time friday night we first
got reports of strong winds a possible
tornado coming here in edwardsville
hitting this amazon warehouse behind me
there's massive damage edwardsville
police have just confirmed for us that
there are two deaths at the moment and
as you guys mentioned this isn't the
only place in the midwest that was hit
hard in the last 12 hours
scenes of destruction like this became
all too common across the midwest
overnight kentucky's governor andy
beshear saying the loss for his state
could be unimaginable the damage is
significant and we expect multiple
fatalities
graves county and specifically the city
of mayfield have been hit really hard
this was the scene in mayfield kentucky
where much of the loss of life is feared
to have taken place a really tough night
i'm on about two hours of sleep
admittedly can't get through to family
that i have
at least 100 emergency vehicles
including a medical helicopter descended
on this illinois amazon warehouse friday
night the storm pummeling the building
until a wall the length of a football
field caved in
dozens of workers were inside when the
wall in the roof above it came crashing
down aisha white was on the phone with a
family member who was inside the
warehouse at the time of the collapse
the tornado was hitting the back of the
building the trucks were coming in i
told him to jump out the truck and duck
we watched the building go up stuff
hitting the cars
i told them i was on my way while
emergency crews searched for anyone who
might be trapped nearly 50 employees
were taken by bus to a local police
station to be checked out the
devastation cutting a wide path across
the nation's midsection a suspected
tornado destroying this home northwest
of st louis and the deadly impact of a
twister at this nursing home in arkansas
it's part of a weather pattern that is
also delivering a blast of winter
weather to the upper midwest
now in just the last several minutes
there were dozens of emergency crews
that have left the scene you can see
over my left shoulder there are still a
few of them here i'm told that they plan
to come back and effort an extensive
search and rescue team back here again
they've been here since about 8 30
friday night that's central time and
we're still learning exactly the
devastation that happened here at this
amazon warehouse in edwardsville
illinois over the last about nine hours
back to you jeff
all right thank you very much jenna ray
of our st louis affiliate kmov we're all
still processing these pictures that are
still coming in here this morning